hallo mein name ist sogar herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video von mir und seht im sale ihr seht
es im titel eingeblendet ich befinde
mich heute mal wieder auf der plattform
oracle und werde dort mit euch video
chatten also in einer gewissen form
skypen war eben noch hier er meinte
einfach so safe tristen wir jetzt noch
keine grüße gehen raus und ich brenne
[Musik]
videodreh bis leider nicht drin
doch du bist drin na gut was gut
dankeschön bitteschön hallo
ciao
ich
höre ich nicht antwortet du einfach im
chat ok immer mit ja und nein
hast du einen namen
warte ja vielleicht so nicht für mich
leider nicht
[Musik]
wie wird
jetzt geht es mir scheiße ich mache nur
ein alter okay das war mega lieben paar
sekunden später unterstrich den
unterstrich warum hast du mikrofon bis
zur apa du machst videos aber hat kein
youtube kanal richtig
youporn möchte von allen guten geistern
verlassen des franchisings und an
manchen stellen schon strange
leider soll ich war dass ich dich sehe
also du sagst du bist mein größter fan
ja dass mein größter fan möchte dann
instagram pushen oder so muss der
unterstrich
der unterstrich ist unterm strich 8 uhr
eingeschrieben
das sehe ich ja jetzt erst ja ok was
folgt alle laser luca
[Musik]
man grüßt in meinem video
ich grüße dich alter danke voll korrekt
von dir
ja wahrscheinlich
was gerade ein video ich habe einfach
nur spaß die ganzen soft boxen und so an
ich habe keine pizza habe ich habe das
hier für dich ich habe ehrlich ja klar
ist ein schrank rauf geklettert alter
was wir sind ja wie viele deiner
beschaffen ja wir sollten heiraten
[Musik]
das war es allerdings auch hier vom
heutigen video meine damen und herren
mit dabei heute der scheißhaufen und
mein größter fan gewesen
was war das für ein deutsch das heutige
video gefallen hat würde ich mich sehr
sehr wohl über einen daumen hoch von
euch freunde einem schaffen hier 50.000
likes freude ich weiß es eine hohe zahl
aber ich glaube an uns ist wieder
schaffen und wenn wir diese zahl
schaffen damit nächsten sonntag auch
wieder eine folge armee gekommen und
jetzt würde ich sagen kann das ist ja
das was jetzt hier vom video hier können
jetzt hier in einen kanal abonnieren
oder hier unten mal einen job
ausschenken jetzt findet ihr zwei andere
videos und wenn ihr schon abonnenten
zeit könnt ihr auch die glocke klicken
dann willkommen die winde nächtigungen
[Musik]